i think the real key to what we did on
superman that made it work was
we really all did check our egos at the
door
superman was the only person that
mattered it was always about the stories
it was always about
where are we going with this stuff
whenever we had a problem
it would be
shouted out let's just kill him
and this was the time where i said okay
wise guys if we kill him then what
happens i says i think we better not
screw up
because this is one of those things we
can do once
we just all agreed and knew that we
didn't want kryptonite to kill him we
didn't want lex luthor to kill him it
had to be something new it had to be
something different and we all voted on
doomsday
at the meeting and we all picked dan's
version from a personality standpoint
the doomsday is so much the opposite
from what superman is you take superman
away
to make people realize that they
actually cared about him and missed him
we really did get the comic stores
interested and we got a lot of new
readers out of it as well you meet
people who at comic book conventions and
they say
oh this was my first comic whole
families were coming out uncles and
aunts
the announcement of this anniversary
edition with all new material has really
gotten a lot of attention even seeing
all the work come across on the 30th
anniversary special
is is a lot of fun to see everybody
working together again for my story it
takes place
a couple of years ago so
young john kent is now about nine or ten
years old and one day someone comes into
school and he's wearing a black armband
with the shield on and he said i'm here
to talk about
one of the most famous days in the
history of metropolis which is the day
that superman died
and young john kept sits there and he
says what that sets us off on a story
that can take us through
kind of a retrospective of what happened
in metropolis during those times and
also
a new villain called doom breaker that
comes into the superman universe now
what was really fun for me in creating a
new superman story was really as
creating a steel story a john henry
irons before he puts on the armor it's
the
15-20 minutes before superman's death
and what he's doing i have to admit i've
always loved
jack kirby's guardian character and
basically have
the guardian's point of view of all
these crazy things were going on
during the
superman and doomsday's chase across
country to metropolis my first thought
on it was really to do something with
mom and pop kent i thought of the
you know just the horrible aspect of
being parents and watching you know
nobody else knows that's your son all
three of the stories are really nice and
i think really will
touch readers it's just great to see
this these collections come out
periodically to remind people
that this was a big deal
[Music]
you